until recently not even the libs thought
that transgender people exist
look no further than the woman who
created the tv show friends friends is
the
absolutely
liberal sitcom par excellence from the
1990s
these people living in new york living
kind of liberal
decadent lives it
pushes a broadly liberal not exclusively
but broadly liberal message and one of
the jokes in the show is that chandler's
father is a transvestite
that was one of the one of the jokes in
the show and now the co-creator marta
kaufman has had to apologize for this
she says we kept referring to chandler's
father
to helena the character as chandler's
father
even though chandler's father was trans
and she suggested that they ought to
have referred to chandler's father once
he had transitioned as chandler's mother
she says pronouns were not yet something
that i understood so we didn't refer to
that character as she that was a mistake
so the whole reason that they had this
character of chandler's father who who
was a transvestite
is because it's funny because men aren't
supposed to do that it was funny and so
the the juxtaposition the incongruity
there is funny and it's supposed to make
you laugh on the situational comedy
but now
we're living in a world of absurdity
we're living in clown world and so the
things that were funny even to the
liberals
20 years ago are now very somber and
serious
and now now this woman marta kaufman the
things she's saying on her apology tour
are much funnier than anything that ever
aired on friends the idea that
when a father
pretends to be a woman that he all of a
sudden becomes your mother
that is that is much crazier even than
saying that a man can become a woman
chandler's father
unfriends i can't believe we're spending
this much time on chandler's father in
this stupid tv show but chandler's
father
even if he puts on a dress even if he
calls himself helena even if everyone
accepts that he is now actually a woman
still would not be chandler's mother
chandler's father did not bear chandler
in his womb
chandler's
father did not give birth to chandler
chandler's father even if he forces
everybody to accept the absurd notion
that he is now a woman chandler's father
cannot possibly ever have been or be now
chandler's mother a mother is an actual
role that that involves having done
something
to another person to be a mother is to
define yourself in a relationship to
another person namely your child
and if you do not have the relationship
of mother and child then you can't
be that mother
this is a rad this is the logical
illogical conclusion of radical
individualism but it reminds us this is
i'm sure marta kaufman did not sign up
for this when she went on her apology
tour about the transvestite jokes but it
actually shows you why the leftist
and
hyper individualist even you sometimes
see it on the right why these views of
humanity are ultimately insufficient
the the view that we're just we're just
living for us just me me all hyper
individualism on the left they talk
about it socially and the right they
tend to talk more economically but the
idea that we are just individuals born
as free-floating atoms that's ridiculous
the way that we view our identities in
society are relational because man is a
social creature the political animal we
define our roles in life in relation to
one another if you're a wife that means
that you have a husband you cannot be a
wife if you don't have a husband if
you're a mother you have to have a child
you cannot be a mother without having a
child
if you're a child a son or a daughter
means you have to have a mother or a
father we are relational beings that's
why you have to have some grasp on
reality because if we're all just living
in our own deluded fantasy lands
we sever the connection that we have to
one another we can no longer even
communicate we can't even use the word
woman right now go to ramp.com
knowles do you want a better way to
simplify your business finances across
expenses
payments accounting if so ramp could be
a complete game changer ramp is a
corporate card and financial software
suite designed to help you save time and
put money back in your pocket ramp gives
finance teams unprecedented control and
insight into company spend with ramp you
are able to create budgets issue cards
to every employee with limits and
restrictions and automate expense
reporting so you can stop wasting time
at the end of every month ramps
accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to i absolutely love this software the
time you will save each month on
employee expenses will allow you to
close your books in days not weeks ramp
saves you money businesses that use ramp
save an average of 3.3 percent the first
year that's a lot of money ramp is easy
to use
get started issue virtual and physical
cards start making payments in less than
15 minutes whether you've got five
employees or five thousand and now get
two hundred fifty dollars when you join
ramp go to ramp.com knowles
ramp.com canadawles
car is issued by celtic bank members
fdic i discovered a contradiction
on dead naming
i did
i i've just on behalf of the transgender
community i discovered a great travesty
that has gone on in hollywood of all
places
ellen page she who must not be named she
who if you name her on twitter you will
be kicked off of twitter and booted out
of the public square ellen page the
actress who now says she's a man and
goes by elliott page
is being dead named dead named that's
when you call someone by their real name
not their new crazy fake name she is
being dead named
by hollywood by the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences by the oscars
if you go on the oscars website
you will notice that they still list
ellen page
under their nominees because she was
nominated for that movie juno
and we all laugh because yes of course
she even if you think that she's a man
now which she isn't she obviously was a
woman in juneau it's a movie it's a
movie about a woman getting an abortion
though i guess you could talk to that
berkeley professor and she'd say that
men can get abortions too we all look at
that we say
ellen didn't call herself elliot in
those days ellen called herself ellen
and knew that she was a woman she's
called herself ellen for 33 of her 35
years on earth so of course but the new
rule on wikipedia on social media on
twitter on on facebook on youtube and
all these places is
if someone now identifies with a new
name and new pronouns you have to refer
to that person by those names by that
name and by those pronouns
when referring to their entire life
and
here
we we see an example of of a
contradiction
the academy we're now halfway into july
the academy still has its pride flag up
on its social media profiles so it says
where the lgbt as lgbt as they come well
they are dead naming
ellen page
are they going to be kicked off of
twitter are they going to be booted out
of the public square are they probably
not they're probably not going to face
any consequences at all but it is rank
hypocrisy the academy gets to dead name
ellen page jordan peterson does not
what's that about well what that's about
is there's two sets of rules i'm so glad
you like that clip i am so close i'm so
close to 1 million subscribers i need
you please i'm asking you've got to ring
that bell like subscribe you've got to
send this channel to your friends say
subscribe right now so that michael can
reach 1 million subscribers and then the
overlords at youtube will completely
nuke his channel and we will accelerate
the liberal
takeover of social media and then we can
finally fight back and get through all
of this madness that's what it's really
this one's really all about folks go
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you